hi I'm brie Larson and this is my wired
auto-complete interview the 100
hundredths wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
so this is the first time ever googled
myself I didn't know it looked like this
is brie Larson I feel like you don't
need to Google this by the way is brie
Larson a gamer great question
duh is brie Larson left-handed why do
you need to know I'm actually
right-handed kind of ambidextrous and I
for Captain Marvel learned how to fight
on both sides so I could do regular in
southpaw is brie Larson well that's
awkward is brie Larson Captain Marvel
I'm sorry that you have to google that I
feel like the Disney execs are super
bummed about that why is brie Larson's
costume green am I allowed to tell you
that I mean it's kind of complicated
like don't you change your style as you
grow and get older it's like whatever
man was the 90s I'd want me to say
where did real Arsene grow up I was born
in Sacramento but moved to Los Angeles
when I was like seven or eight something
like that I don't really like him when
people ask that question like where are
you from because then I say Los Angeles
and they go it's crazy from Los Angeles
no one's from Los Angeles actually
Sacramento and they're like no way I'm
from Sacramento where did you grow up I
grew up and I'm like I don't know
Sacramento and they're like it's just
hard you know did brie Larson go to
we're never gonna know go to college
no I almost walked into a buffet on the
way here it's a wonder that I even made
it to this interview really why didn't I
go how do I explain this I'm just not
that good at it I love to learn but I'm
not good at sitting still those real
Larssen have siblings yes I do I have a
younger sister does brie Larson sing ha
why did you have to google that doesn't
everybody saying would brie Larson work
out like hypothetically would I at some
point is that like a personal attack or
something is that a request do you think
I should uh yeah I work out a lot thanks
for asking um okay I'll do the side brie
Larson I'm scared real arson dog I'm
confused is it are you asking if I have
two dogs or is it just like dog like
real I said dog I have two I like dogs
maybe it's because I'm severely allergic
to cats that I've really taken two dogs
as being like a dog person brie Larson
Jeep that kind of makes sense I did push
my trainer's Jeep for 60 seconds at a
slight incline so that was really cool
brie Larson rock climbing he asked more
Boulder climbing into her Boulder
climbing hoping to climb the Tetons in
August with Jimmy and Alex from
preschool oh so training to do that
right now
brie Larson Lady gaga I mean I don't
even know like why on earth would you do
that have I ever mentioned Lady Gaga is
Lady Gaga talking about me is that why
she's never mentioned me so I don't know
why that's there I feel like I need to
do a google of this Google who is
Captain Marvel let's start at the
beginning
Captain Marvel is a character that is
now in the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
I play her in the movie version of it
her origin story is that she was a Air
Force pilot and something spectacular
happened to her and now she has
superpowers who is Captain Marvel is
kind of a controversial question there's
a lot of different versions of Captain
Marvel Captain EO was actually a DC
Comics one point was a dude then became
a woman was wearing a leotard had a sash
changed her costume also had a mask
don't have the mask anymore helmet no
helmet long hair short hair mohawk a lot
of different illustrators made by women
now super badass but you know it's
really up to you to decide who is your
captain marvel but I know who - does
Captain Marvel have a cat yes kind of
depends on if you're talking about the
movie or the comics but Kat is
definitely involved chewy in the comics
goofs of the movie does Captain Marvel
time travel no I don't time travel I
mean I understand it's a little
confusing with the time lapse but like
she uses good skincare just don't worry
about it
how a Captain Marvel gets her powers can
I say
no one from Marvel's here ok great
Captain Marvel gets her powers from a
crazy blast but don't try to do that
yourself I've never tried but I
experienced it in the movie and it's not
so nice you're probably better off just
like scooting around on the carpet and
creating an electric charge and then
shocking people safer can Captain Marvel
beat Superman I can't believe you even
have to google that duh
brie Larson who does brie Larson look
like I mean why
who is brie Larson stunt double I have
to ranae moneymaker and Johanna Bennett
so maybe that answers that question how
tall is brie Larson like five five eight
ish five eight and a half which is
specific but I'm really just gonna eat
out everything that's now how old is
brie Larson's character in room honestly
I feel like I should google that I don't
know I have no idea
Kim brie Larson speak French this is
something that is worth googling because
it's a little complicated and confusing
so that my history with French is it was
my first language when I was a child my
family is french-canadian but by the
time I was in like maybe first or second
grade I started speaking more English
and it kind of died out I've taken
French a couple of times I actually try
to take it in college but then I didn't
last very long in college as we've
discussed previously but I keep trying I
keep getting like a dual lingo account
and trying again and sometimes in
interviews like yesterday I had people
speaking to me in French and I was like
I'm gonna do this and then a very
quickly I'm like oh I don't remember
this there's like certain things that I
remember from my childhood like my
stomach was upset the other day and so I
was remembering that I was told that
that was called beau Sood which is like
sour ball sour sour stomach sour sour
ball in your stomach I did actually
google that the other night and it
didn't pop up as that
I'm not sure if I was learning some sort
of slaying French but I'll get back on
the French train students now that I
feel completely accosted by this Google
search Thank You wired for this
opportunity to Google myself for the
first time y'all are crazy out there but
also I just think it's weird that even
Google me in the first place
so thanks